Yes. With the epping of the children you mean. Some of the kids are quite nice but. A lot of them.
But it's probably not just the paper from here i think it's a general trend everywhere.
Kids have no respect for anyone or anything anymore. That's more oil device ins.
Than i but i think it's probably it just doesn't relate to the people of name and i think it relates to the maybe way.
You know. Some of our grandchildren are growing up here in name. And at the moment and.
I have a sixteen year old and eleven year old. But i don't even want to go up the street. I just.
And my four year old grandson.
If we're walking along the street we have to go past the rainbow cafe he will sort of stand back
and so i do we have to walk this way nana. That's from a four year old so. What do you judge out of that.
By at the other two grand kids don't they get off their school bus or get loose more school
and get off the school bus and go home and that's because of these
and then that hangs straight at all not want to see you. Experience of the drug.
I don't see a lot of it happening around with my job at the moment.
We don't see a lot of it would probably be a lot of evidence that we've done. Just sort of. You know.
So you come in contact with a lot of it my husband does he. Gets a bit disgusted it turns with.
Nader's lawing around him. What everybody has to pick up. That sort of thing.
And i don't know are going to alter that or the been trying to do that for a couple of years now his net.
So you can you joke. You know what you saw day. Yeah i did.
Yes and there is i don't know whether it's because the people who are into consuming alcohol
or nothing else to do with a time. But i certainly white. For dull die and. And they sort of.
They're off they face for the first couple of guys with the influence of alcohol so i mean it certainly has its
problems as well. Where you were you know one of the.
Well i say name in advancing in the next couple of years now as sewage systems going through what they say to be a big
demand for lane then what have you so i think that nimbin will thrive. Particularly now. Hopefully when you.
And i want to be anywhere else but limit. These days. I don't really know i would never leave. But my kids. You know.
Yes it's. It's so much different to anywhere else. You know. But.
Some good things some bad things so i think it's a good place for the kids to. To be brought up and.
What else can i say that was when i was born at more. Lived at a place they call.
Blue note and that's just through on the toy. Border.
I went to school and annoyed when i did to my finish my primaries going. I did three.
Been traveling to nimbin on the bus.
And when i finished there i came to naman and started work
and have been here ever since what was there very very good we we had my day ron ron. And plaintiveness wiggins.
They instead you know out of the way. And in those days. We didn't worry man.
Alcohol or anything with them we really had a good time.
I think probably the kids of today are missing out on the top it's a good time to used to have i'm not as interested in
sport in email. More like we were. You know. I'd like to say that it sort of take a swing back to that.
So that you get the kids do something rather than. Hang around the streets and. You know. Band laws and property and.
All that sort of stuff. So i think they've drawn heaps wise to draw on. And so the town.
But it just doesn't always work. Some kids. I just. Rebels you know i just don't want to sort of think that you say oh.
Don't do that i just don't. And then you know i just get pleasure out of doing it i believe.
But i think that's general to it's not just human and also probably or. You know. Getting a bit discussed and.
I mean we never did those who were things i don't think they should do and what so and good.
I think of the last five years. Newman's. Sort of. The quality of people who come here as. Is trying.
I think i'm not saying. Name been as. High even to. To practice. They have but it's a much i.
My seem to think that they can come here and do it freely and not anything happen to them and. That seems to attract.
All that sort of person. Ministerial some you know it's people coming into that. We certainly have their share of the.
The ones who will. Leave a big debate is oh i'm it's i don't know. Ok you type what is just a symbol of.
Who is the most money going to need and then to resell it to them ira.
If you think he's going to forty two columns straight.
And during the festival i work the dies he do it at the back with you the reason you didn't before. My squad.
Let's go out of the mail for everyone kind of tandem said i moaning zoeth buzz. You know.
Wasn't lost on a lot in nimbin before the festival. Was why i don't know whether david died.
The cattle industry and that sort of thing was all gowing.
Shops with lies ing but i think there would always been a few shops in name.
Then i think we would have died completely it was actually a shock. Well i had mixed feelings.
I did have mixed feelings. I can't be responsible for having it because i wasn't here when i bided it in rats.
I was all a dying alive but i don't regret having it.
And i regret saying you know what a lot can remember them doing here in front of you not doing their own thing.
This moralists. Sort of marching them out surprise got down on the fields and and do it all and i didn't sort of.
I wasn't involved in it probably that when you. When you say it was you know you know i just i'm getting prepared for.
In the fields with the war looked and. This fixing it up in general and sort of.
Spies getting a bad talking to put on getting to know them i think i'm dr madam quite well live as a talk on the by
where he is.
And i think some of them still feel that some of them are gone but some of them still is by bermuda ridge
and i sort of started that. Thing when it was just simon if i had learned to handle.
I think we stood behind a counter from ford i dies
and thought i know it's just so playful there was just nothing else to say it was just side busy.
You know what i think at that time. And i was a bad or you could side that was just simon if i had to look.
It was on radio. That a small tan lightening been good. Just have so many people. I mean. Can you just sort of.
So i'm rambling. And larry's some of some wonderful eyes to the most rides were wonderful.
And to sort of stood there thinking will we ever get out of this applies to lock in habit that we had not a driver
behind that cannot and it does
but we're probably tend to eat a lot it's i was probably live a very patient people as we would do
but i thought why would i want to know many of us things happen so hard that just so a lot of those a lot of drinking
us. As there was. But that's what it was all about wasn't it was a fist of oak was.
I think the biggest luck with i didn't know what do you. You know i don't think we did. Really truly that.
Most of us because we would know if we didn't expect them to stop by and then
when you think back you think what would you expect that we didn't expect them to stop it just didn't.
That are that regret that.
Some of them have started off a set of mud some good friends out of the bible that have kind of after the festival.
You know.
And that's with us a buzz you know if we ran it up to did come from with the fist of a limit and be a lot of them.
He and they and their children some of the children would be a but there is some of them still here and there is
but lot of us just saw many people in that fort knox you couldn't cite.
When yes i got tonight is this a number some of them that we did get to know. It was you know.
Two young girls that we sort of got to talk to him. And that sort of thing.
You're talking about happy memories of festivals now.
Probably one of the things that often records that are really enjoyed. Was.
We shot the shop side for two way out from the. Two o'clock in the morning decline.
And there was a fairly broad and i'm of dennis.
And he used to come along with these guitar and we used to dance in this room in dies you know and to wait. And again.
And that was greit that was fun. Just the stuff from dennis pynoos guitar.
And that sort of and he was part of that system working in that that to my it was something that i will remember.
Personally from that festival in that fort i mean the actual fourteen dies at that festival that would be something
that i would remember with a lot of joy. Well we always said that we would have an island little paddy.
More labor minerals was sort of. Have been the scene there. And it was. And we had. You know it was probably on.
Ten or twelve of us that worked in guises in the long sheath so sid.
You sort of think of it and think you never went to bed
but they had a bath in abuja so i told them to just sort of pulled out of god's light and get up and keep going again.
And you did do that but now i've got fond memories of.
Some of those things that happened during that for i think a lot of said things of coming out.
Not from that actual fist of what you know along that twenty news.
That has a normal brain on the full sense thing that can use.
So well and shops you know that the aa think the town has grown and it's still early when the place.
There was a lot of. What your side.
Disputes in how things it just didn't strides
and if these are spread you could call it just didn't so yard a lot because.
And i think that came from the fact that we thought that his play but we're going to pack it up and god.
In twenty years what we have he nailed. I think we've become very tolerant of one another and now.
I think that things have even themselves they are i'm not signing that.
We don't get cross with one another at times and that. And i suppose we get cross with you jabba. You know happened.
I think we've become. With come along why. In twenty years that we can side that.
We act tolerant of one another nail and we can. You know this issues that we will never bring on. But. Yeah.
Can sort of this and sort of do along the way our way and you know and that sort of thing about him and even his kind.
On the simon has a seven heels to so many beautiful climbs up in the heels is.
You know some papers on his or her legs how bees in heels but you've got to get out there in the eyes heels and say.
And there is lovely.
Was in those heels that those playful have put them up
and sometimes i think the tan maisonneuve was clane as it used to be but then my new gown from probably.
What a couple of players and i thought i'm probably thirty sanson play
but sometimes just those at the moment so you can expect that anyway enough we can create a small town kleinman it's
just sort of got more playful in a day that i read as an obvious job of writing at kleinman. You know.
This daunting thing that's going to you know it's definitely ties.
But i don't think it's for the worse a path and i have said we have a drug problem here
but then i suppose it's everywhere i don't know. I haven't travelled a lot.
This is higher than that from a holiday at the bridge or somewhere like that you just sort of hear.
So that now where they have bigger problems and what we've got anywhere and live you know it's true.
Since early in the price i think.
You now need to run around without their claws on although i think that's gone too i think people have become.
I have been from that so out of this because i'm aware that.
Now we're with you but we're not going to just think this sort of crime here
and so it will not listen to a fact of life and that's what we're going to do.
But then i realize that not everybody was seeing to that so that stopped.
You know that has been caught wales and not not a lot of money lots of things
and i think if you didn't laugh at them you wouldn't leave him going to sense if you me that live in neiman you really
go with that but it will discount. What's it's just anything. You know when it's organized. Loftier naman.
When you come in limply you throw in a fortnight and you'll say what on line. It's. It's different.
Just different living here. You've got a. You've got a lot name. And believe in it. This is for sure. I think it has.
I think it hits us and what we print. All right one another in the beginning of that. So i know.
Ron up until probably doing year ago i think we you know we think. Oh my god.
You know we're going to go up to events or even funny.
And we think most of us got to a study where you sort of said oh we live just arab lives more we didn't.
Dad tailpipe what we believed in him meant. And that now you do you say as we leave the room and you know.
We're proud of that fact that. So yes we've we've all grown up. Oh all of us i think.
And then has grown on with ground up together. And that's something that we should be proud. Supplants.
Well i had john wayne in the oldest and then the festival was the following nine. So. Wendy.
The oldest would be about ita
and i would have went to school together during that this time i'm not going to remove the time that we're devoting
nothing we've had one walk through the fields you know. And that's an attack and only contact.
Oh mummy and ruth they've got my plan as i'm so you know mommy sort of grabbed them and ran off because i didn't know.
Those brave little. You know as i would let them.
Look i enjoyed it i think you know what guys to our ones would remember albert.
When he would remember it more than anything else
but i didn't sort of get add a lot because he would move on the straights in that fortnight but after that.
In this sort of from group way that was the one never encouraged him.
You know you run you going to have some dried friends done to bring him.
Because i think nice kids sort of ran through this has as much as anybody's kids you know and.
Carriage that i sort of felt that was important that if that we're all going to school together the thought i had to be
that we're all children. And i belong to somebody. And that was.
I always sort of this sort of that that was the why we were going to god that you know that bible
or children out there together and that's what we we wanted for them. And i think it's a done the most good the.
Rounding up in name and i think at jordan ladder lot. And i didn't.
I think i really think that i i did that night and i learned a lot through being in that twenty is.
During and after that this is a phone. I'm not disappointed i rate them. Well mine only through not so much with.
Parents i think about think.
I was more concerned about the education department thought of getting me into more of these free education instead of
you know going in a classroom doing things that was my.
Amount of speaking from the way i was used to the our why of schooling and that's what i wanted from our children.
To spill. The line i did that and i think. I still think that. And it was you know.
But moves fast now i don't think that the idea about you know the kids or anything. And you know i think i was.
I was in some cases i would sign now you can't guide that person supplies because it was a can mean situation
or something and i didn't know about it so i didn't sort of argue well fraud
or anything like that without the parents you know i think that any of that children that my children got to know the
parents in our sort of had a thing as well. Even that we know one another. It's not. You know. We didn't sort of.
The of rinds roots of one another time logs that.
And because i lived here in town i'll surprise you know after the years it was sort of.
Easy for monday when school starts it was on the kids could come here and get dressed and go off to school
and then the moms would come and pick them up leider
and then that was sort of a my thing like that that probably ma kids.
Didn't get out of the communism that a lot but i sort of. Went after.
As a group of kids in north to try things that was on more than slaving in times and that. To get them but.
I said if i had to live again i would do it.
To sign my own citizens were really not because i didn't know a lot so it was probably a lot lighter in our logs that.
We met a young couple. And i had traded her children and we did. Got a ton of acromion and by noon they heineman.
And things like that and that was.
To us was probably an eye opener because you know you hear those things early
or run around on communes with flies on a night. This and. Oh wait we had a lovely die.
On ton of a family and in the end we didn't say. Very many playful adore you know that.
And night my certainly all implies on i'm on admin with them.
So early in the post when our kids with it we didn't know. We were learning. What we were learning.
And so we didn't i want to but what sort of things went on.
You know because we'd know where you had a veil and we wasn't living in. Group of people.
We didn't know what we were so much sort of crazy to cyanide and a very sort of.
Why are you back in the water by doing. Straights. You know i think we all had that sign madia that.
The room giving me update you now. Am i living in that. I don't think there was any real room is a bath.
Because now i was the one the people that lived did none of us knew what was.
When you that bought some land and we are not i think when you were a month i was leaving when that living in tents
or for an hour what your child was going to actually like sleeping when i got there where the.
It's going to be bedded down on a blanket under the stars of what we didn't know we did we didn't rumah what was
happening because we didn't. We we honestly didn't know i would leaving out there.
And office it was years lyda that we actually were given the opportunity to go on to that property and and.
So that i did at normal as the sun was what went on and. So possibly now. If i had a daughter of science.
I do not be quite happy. If i knew that there at the site is good. You know i'm happy but deep down you're a guy.
Or i wouldn't. I'm not good because i didn't know.
But now that i've been there and often are now that they've gotten lost homes the same as not the whole but the.
Dyad leaving. To walk by can afford them.
Probably because i'm older of them so i want to stop and understand that it's constant.
You know it's fifteen years for them to get that size ready because we're still getting this ready you have to twenty
six years you know there's lots of things to do.
But when i was younger i was probably not as tall
or single you know that probably living up to about a box of things but no plane they its own nail and. Yes.
Oh yes we've all wizened this but then you look at it now. But when we bought it. It was four rooms.
And the brand was falling off it so i was.
It wasn't very out past the weird sort of arrival of a sad twenty six sort of. Paddling along the do up. You know.
That's
and that's why our son now can read light to the eyes put the thought of up there with two rooms it's where the ball
yes we've expanded the brain the role. We thought we got a bathroom or know something lot that. There's you.
You've done a disservice but not us when you younger us by.
Young children need that think more than enough to broaden the law and think oh i wouldn't my kids go up there
but i think we were all the same we were not to say we didn't expect them to start so we didn't expect them
and we didn't know what they were doing when i did bought that land up there or how they were leaving.
We had all sorts of fun.
This morning on the hour that now what we would have done you know and we probably just done what had to be done.
Said sandro at the side that you know like us but we're still doing it. You know in a funny sort of why if you say.
Some. Someone needs help or someone's got a little you know. And i think you just do it.
That's a mother's instinct to do that and think that you know how and because we would be in that shop.
With something you just want to look up the kids. You know you talk to young people that were really dan.
When my dad was in a will and a lot of times young kids guy me and i didn't know what they were doing
when i got here right that moment if you could lend a helping hand.
We are no cattle they are not on the last bus we had a few arguments to walk and remember once when i went
and got a kid out of a katherine all the things you do you know.
And it was dormant on the job with crohn's and i went and.
The mother put it back to a matter of this sort of way no one did just anything in dinner last night
and there was some lovely young girls can be that. That got depressed months i got here.
I didn't have a lot i had to come here but i think with this big data getting on let's go. And.
So you know i don't as you're talking to them that they are more tolerant
and i would have been if that have just grown up this three kids in this.
I don't know whether we're to still had a school. You know i'm going back when he would have started school.
Here but i'm sure that it would've. You know we didn't have a lot of. Jordan and we got a big school now.
So i might he wouldn't let us go a lot and i but i think that they they are more tolerant.
Jordan than i would have been had this not happened like that and i had to explain.